people know Bob music everywhere all
around the
world but Bob was more than just a
musician this movie brings to the world
about Marley that not a lot of people
know from the day I born I never know so
much
struggle we tell the story of Bob's
life his music
and his connection with the
people it was a tremendous honor to help
share Bob's story to have the backing of
the family it was really a
blessing all the family is glad to be
part of this you tell different sides of
Bob everybody here know the culture know
the vibe it's a very communal
Endeavor one love one art one destiny
all right my father was a messenger of
peace and
love is people music people coming
together at that time Jamaica was a war
zone between two political sides and so
Bob's message became the answer to
violence and
strife you can't separate the music and
the message what is the message peace so
going right now the really need a love
that's in the music Bob is such a
unifying figure and he's creating a
Revolution have
love music com to unify the
people when we audition and I saw
Kingsley he was just in a different
level he represent my father very well
and it was not just B the legend or Bob
the artist or Bob the singer but the
human side and the emotional side my
life is is not important to me my life
is for people the process of trying to
get to know B and trying to convey the
magnetism of his Charisma it's been
lifechanging for sure no guns can stop
this message I want the World to Change
and that time is
no